hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update according to a recent report
EA is working on a new battlefield title
called battlefield hardline references
to the game were found in ea's own
Battlelog source code with a logo for
the game as well as indications that
it's going to come to xbox one Xbox 360
Playstation 4 playstation 3 and pc the
unofficial twitter account battlefield
daily has discovered various icons for
the game including images of weapons
vehicles equipment ranks and awards a
logo for Visceral Games was also noticed
which suggests that they are the
possible developer there are no plot
details at this time but an image
portraying SWAT and thieves team logos
add fuel to rumors of a police themed
game EA has not officially announced a
new battlefield game so be aware that
this info is currently unconcerned if
details on battlefield hardline are to
be believed this might be one of the six
games that EA is going to be revealing
at this year's press conference and
GameSpot is going to be on hand with
analysis and a complete recording of the
press conference so stay tuned